now our last scientific and engineering
award goes to ZBrush software where you
had ZBrush ZBrush was a game changer
because it was the first of its kind
prior to ZBrush digital models were
created by sculpting figures in clay and
scanning them to produce 3d assets this
took weeks and was quite costly also
digital artists had to be technically
savvy ZBrush enabled a new workflow
where the technical aspects are
essentially invisible to the artist
allowing them to concentrate solely on
shape this opened the door to a much
broader but less technical sophisticated
user the impact on production has been
huge
whether done in ZBrush or systems
inspired by ZBrush it's now a standard
in every major studio it has a unique
set of real time sculpting and texturing
tools for sculpting of digital models
because of ZBrush and artists could make
changes more quickly with a director
seated right next to him for the for the
design and implementation of the
revolutionary ZBrush software tool the
Academy presents its scientific and
engineering award to a4 along Wow hold
on hold on
I can tell you that I've never tweeted
in my life but this would be a great
reason to do one so as someone who came
from Israel 30 years ago I was inspired
by simply watching movies on Victorine
never would I think that I would be able
to contribute to the magic of
moviemaking
in fact I'll tell you story about how
much Muslim means to me is I was born in
Israel and lived in a house that was
sharing a wall with a movie theater for
me to see a movie all I needed to do is
jump over the wall and I've done this
plenty of time with permission but I did
and now I was way too young to
understand what movies mean so for me
everything that I've seen on the movie
was real when someone dies on the screen
I believe that they really died so after
the movie I was sad but then I got the
impression that movies are so important
that people are willing to die to be in
a movie so this is where I got so this
is this is where I got my my feeling
about what movie they are worth dying
for
so obviously then you can understand
that there's no way I would imagine at
any time in the future I will be able to
get an award recognizing me for
contributing to this magic of movies for
that I'd like to thank the Academy for
honoring me with this award and for
giving me a reason to tweet and wear a
tuxedo at the same time
I like to check it share this award with
my partner Giacomo is sitting right
there
jockey mark Jack thank you jack this
would not have been possible without you
- Jaime level and the pixologic team who
have worked tirelessly and passionately
in helping making zbrush what it is
today
and special thanks to all the ZBrush
artists who have inspired us to do more
to do better and to break new ground to
my family abroad or with encouraging me
to follow my dreams and to my two
daughters Karen and Danielle and my
beautiful wife Mickey sitting right
there thank you not only that you have
helped me achieve goals without you
there will be no reason to have goals to
begin with I love you
that's good yeah we need to take a
minute it's really soupy I'm single can
you believe that first of all once again
it's time to take a little break for
some coffee and some desserts um we'll
be back with the John a Boehner medal of
commendation the Gordon I saw you award
and is in a special Academy Award of
Merit in just a few moments